esports just wouldn't be esports without
a healthy dose of trash talk but if
you're going to talk [ __ ] off the server
you better make sure you can back it up
in-game too today we are going to be
paying tribute to some of the most
incredible moments when people talk
trash and got clapped the talk [ __ ] get
hit moments of esports but before we get
into that i want to make sure you are
all sub to the channel and have
notifications turned on because it
really does matter alright let's get
into it here are the top 10 trash talk
disasters in esports history
kicking off our list is a reminder that
no matter what esport you're into the
age old naeu rivalry always delivers
heading into the matchup between version
1 and team liquid at the vct stage 2
masters in reykjavik it's safe to say
that the one tap legend himself scream
was fairly confident that his roster
would come out on top hey hey we're
coming for you
uh but i do think europe is is a bit
better like i think
obviously the sentinels have like
amazing players individually but
i feel like what they do is very uh
predictable needless to say vanity v1's
rowdy rambunctious cat-eared in-game
leader wasn't so sure about the
supremacy europe was so quick to profess
in europe it's just people playing
they play for kills they play to like
molly the bomb it's the same thing in
north america and i think that the
notion that the europeans utility is
just way better is just not true of
course as soon as they set foot into the
server and v1 started rallying rounds it
became clear scream hadn't just
underestimated astra he underestimated
na as a whole nobody actually from
liquid falling back here so they might
even just get detained link goes forward
penny gonna trade one out link swinging
through someone's gonna trade out
finally he's he's detained
he's gonna stand as watch as v1 against
all the odds against all the doubt rise
above
and bring the first win for north
america above europe
taking the ninth spot on our list is a
beatdown that stems from a spicy beef
between two members of cod royalty it
all started in june 2021 when formal
woke up one morning and chose violence
who do you wish you dropped but never
did kim six
back in black ops three who do you want
the butt imagine that's so
quarantine and online competition had
been extremely rough for optic they
hadn't been playing up to their usual
standard and came short in some truly
devastating series but they were gearing
up to dominate on lan at the cdl stage
four major and they might have had they
not come up against krimsik's roster
dallas empire he's actually trying to do
what he can he has to go but they find
him they have the close spawns and that
might be it envoy trying to fly
just a couple seconds needed an empire
take both hard points they take the
series
look talk smack all you want just make
sure you hit your shots so you can back
it up coming in at number eight is the
fateful but unintentional shade that a
journalist from french counter-strike
outlet vikarm threw onto stewie2k
heading into cloud9's quarterfinal match
against g2 at the 2018 e-league boston
major and the miracle run that ensued
hello maxine from vacam we have a
question from for stewie uh how do you
feel to play again against g2 uh because
you will lose against them so
yeah what's your feeling uh
now due to the language barrier the
journalist actually misspoke what he
meant to say was that c9 had previously
lost to g2 but it didn't matter that was
all the fire that's dewey needed to do
the impossible
stewie he hears it
apex stepping a little bit too soon
now body in so much trouble but kenny's
gonna be on the high ground getting the
kill
he almost went down himself there's body
picking it up and now it's a one versus
one stewie versus kenny the smell of
gunfire and freedom in the air and
stewie picking up that kill and cloud
niner in the semi finals look no one not
even north americans themselves expected
cloud9 to win such a cutthroat
competitive major but if there's one
thing that's guaranteed to turn an
underdog into a powerhouse it's some
good old-fashioned elitism so on behalf
of nacs stands everywhere thank you
bakar
taking the seventh spot on our list is a
throw that will live on in league of
legends infamy when tsm brought on star
european carries then to round out their
world's hungry roster at the tail end of
2017 the expectation was that he'd give
north america a run for its money more
specifically that he'd give doublelift a
run for his money since that's the goat
he replaced i hope team liquid can have
a perfect record against tsm shoot on
them in the finals if they make it there
i wanna absolutely demolish tsm's legacy
and make sure that they regret that
decision needless to say zven wasn't
deterred stirring up some choice words
of his own because douglas is good right
he's skilled and he can carry games by
himself
but when he can't carry because his
opponent is as good as him or maybe even
better
despite liquid rallying their way to a
game five this venom has such a huge
lead in the deciding bout that it seemed
all but impossible they could throw it
and then out of nowhere does venn not
only threw away his life but the finals
entirely kink detective all right this
he is down what is he doing
[Applause]
um and while sven did go on to redeem
himself with cloud9 he'll always be
remembered at least in part for flying
just a little bit too close to well the
baron pin
coming in at number six is an ever
important reminder to keep the tweets in
your drafts folder until after you win
the match that's right league fans it's
time for the infamous clap faker message
that c9s jensen sent to the world before
their face off at world 2016. look we
get it playing against the single
greatest league player of all time on
your game's biggest stage can afford you
with not only an adrenaline rush but a
certain let's say confidence the thing
is faker is the goat for a reason he's
[ __ ] on jensen hard thing he can find an
opening here yeah jensen kind of got
poked down he does have sums of fingers
getting at the start planned it back he
flashes forward and first blood goes to
willie fight the disadvantage they're
now playing with yeah c9 they're playing
a similar style as they did in playoffs
where they leave he's like on an island
oh good again faker looking for the all
in just it does get the stun oh wolf is
here to complete this gonna be a drake
yeah c9 mimicking that style from
playoffs another oh no it's another stun
combo yeah what goes in now it's the
combo through and the altis the easy
whoop hey gets another one remember kids
if you're gonna come at the king best
not miss
sitting at the halfway point on our list
is a scuffle between snipe down and
lethal that's still sizzling to this day
now these days you may know snipe down
as one of tsm's star apex legends
players but once upon a time he was a
household name in halo esports in fact
he was such a force to be reckoned with
the competitors started memeing on how
good he was in an effort to thwart and
topple him hey neighbor can you hear me
yeah i can hear you all right so how's
it going how you feeling coming into
this event oh i'm really nervous and
scared because you know snipe down he's
like the best player and uh it's just it
makes it really tough uh
it's hard to focus when he's playing
he's just so sick needless to say it
didn't work and now it's gotta be
neighbor's turn he's got 31 seconds on
the clock but he's gonna be racking up
the kills with the battle rifle and
right now his job is going to be watch
back orange and make sure no one comes
up on open side as legit sneaks through
and there's t2 and just once again the
team shot from stranger i'll tell you
what so when two years later snipe
down's former teammate and new rival
lethal co-opted that exact same trash
talk to try to psych the boy out at x
games aspen 2016 it definitely raised a
few eyebrows probably sniped on he's
like
the best player he's just so sick you
know
i get really worried when i see him and
you know it's just the stuff he does is
insane and like his predecessor the man
got absolutely bopped at the weapons
they had the power up and look at this
they fight running away
take it down snipe down in the eg squad
smell blood as they have 49 kills and
frosty's gonna get killed as well by
snipe down here's the new combo and look
at what it means to evil geniuses your x
games gold medalist just erupt in the
booth you know what they say those who
can't remember the past are doomed to
repeat it except in this case he did
remember it he just chose to meme on it
ripped to him i guess eric there were
some words exchanged before the
interview during the interview with
lethal tell me i mean
wall she made a few comments about how
you not do not want to fire you up you
don't want to strike a match to gasoline
how fired up were you in that first
series in the first game i told them
before it started the last person that
said it to me lost the series and they
lost the series too so uh if you're
going to talk trash you better back it
up and we took that serious home
our number four entry is a moment in
fighting game history that put a height
spin on an age-old piece of socratic
wisdom if a man refuses to know himself
tell him about himself that's right it's
time for the bout between two long time
beefers k brown and wolf crone at final
round 20. heading to the event these
street fighters headed out for each
other they'd faced off multiple times
and no matter the result one of them
always ended up salty
now he's telling every excuse oh i just
can't deal with i just don't know how
you know every excuse is coming out the
book now
he was giving me a compliment though but
i understand that but he's also making
an excuse for himself
for why he lost i couldn't adapt in
match i couldn't adapt and match that's
me saying you were the better player
right now what do you what are you
saying what what do you want the thing
is even when cabrera had tried to show
his rival some respect he was met with
not only a cold shoulder but a
contemptuous one i don't know i don't
got to do the whole cold hands i don't
got to do the cold get my chest
stop talking shut your mouth real quick
so
so
for one for one second for one second
shut up
i'm trying to tell you that you did
something good you idiot now listen
listen
so when k brad put this dude in the dirt
at final round he popped off
oh my goodness oh wait wait
but it's looking like a marble match oh
no
oh this is frank
let me see this oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
tell him
tell him about himself tell him about
himself let him know him tell him about
himself talk to him tell him about
himself tell him about himself it's like
that's what i'd like to see
standing third on our podium is a
rivalry whose flavor will never be able
to wash out of our mouths the time that
viscant all too figuratively [ __ ] on
low tier god how many times have you had
intentions of only playing a game for an
hour to look up and about three or four
hours have passed and you forget to do
anything else you forgot to shower you
forgot to eat you even forget to take a
piss keeping up with those habits
continuously will have you looking like
this guy
i made a video the first guy i could
think of
on why gamers were single was verscon
this dude looks like he lives in his
basement he looks like he never gets sun
he could possibly be a [ __ ] vampire
suffice to say viscant showed up with
some choice words for this fool
it goes back further than that he's been
disrespecting me for a while
i already beat him i beat him 20 to six
i don't even know why we're having this
match except for the fact that he keeps
using my name and then he keeps ducking
me i mean if you're gonna talk [ __ ] then
don't duck if you're gonna talk then
back it up if you're gonna be a [ __ ]
then run like a [ __ ] more importantly
he showed that he had the moves to back
those words up i'm sorry i'm getting
there
and that's it and that's it
is popping off he is popping off right
now
he is pulling off the shirt's top
handshake this
why would we shake hands we do not shake
hands in crunch matches
but it was after viscant totally shat on
ltg that he really put the dude in a
body pack there's gonna come a point
when you forget about what happened
and you're going to want to come back at
me
and you're going to want to wash the
taste of my dick out of your mouth
[Applause]
taking the runner spot on our list is
the anime grade betrayal that took place
between the so-called dota brothers fly
and no tail just three months before the
international 2018. what was that like
going through that change
i'm actually not that willing to talk
about it yeah it's uh
something for later another day for
years fly and no tail were inseparable
both as competitors and companions at
this point og with no tail and fly four
majors it's an achievement that i don't
think we'll ever see
anyone be able to reach again in the
world of dota 2. but after years of
failing to make anything happen at ti
they began to fall off before long their
team og were a shadow of their former
selves and why well fly thought the team
was the problem so in the most
tear-jerking roster move ever he
abandoned his so-called brother to seek
victory on evil geniuses
why did you leave og the team hasn't
worked for a long time
and i can say personally that i lost a
lot of motivation when the whole
situation arised where i could join eg
i felt a new surge of motivation where i
felt like this is really a team
i could win with needless to say he was
very
very wrong i can't recount the whole
anime arc right now since it'd take a
while but basically og not only
qualified for ti without fly but won it
slapping the fly led evil geniuses along
the way what unbelievable comebacks we
have between these two teams in two
back-to-back games
oh gee with the fortitude to stick
through it after dealing with such
importance
oh the look there from no sir oh yeah
and did i mention the same thing
happened to ti9 as well if this isn't
the definition of [ __ ] around that find
out i don't know what is
taking the top spot on our list is the
musically accompanied showdown between
smash's godslayer leffen and the guy
went the extra mile to call him out
chillin
dude i'll be blowing you up who said you
were a god i know it wasn't plot been
here ten years and you know i'm showing
up for a man in many words i think you
said enough chilin is a veteran of the
melee scene and back in 2015 he wasn't a
fan of leffen's youthful arrogance and
allowed mouth hottie to meet her
especially since the fox mane outraged
trash chillin on social media so chillin
got a little rhythmic with his response
releasing a literal diss track but the
only way to make your hush first our
body bag your fox then dies if it shut
imma put you in your place kid you were
disgraced get killed quick like that
missile hit you in the face
unfortunately despite children's asian
experience when talk of a grudge match
started to come up leffen didn't take
him seriously at all he even went as far
to guarantee a 5-0 the thing is if
you're going to go as far as releasing a
diss track you really have to be able to
back it up and chillin well he most
certainly did not back it up nice dash
dances for chillin chillin
still some fight left in him he can make
this big
wait the knockdown
that's another smash and a 5-0 right now
chillin gets dethroned he is not using
this color fox anymore as the years have
gone on chilling's wrap has gone from a
meme to a genuinely beloved piece of
melee war he's etched himself into the
history of esports even if some people
can't get over the part where he got
clapped nemesis dude
i've been making fun of them all week
the joke was your life would have been
so much better if you just beat leffen
and every time something went wrong i'm
like if you beat leffen that wouldn't
happen
so his whole life was just
damn revolved around that moment
alright folks that's our list did we
miss any notable trash talkers that got
absolutely clapped let us know in the
comments if we did and i'll see you all
next
oh time i love it yes
stewie's got that and the follow-up
great elise
they mentioned both in fact yeah that is
i'm so happy i'm just out